a tricky question
on this just to stay in this a little
longer because i'm not sure how to think
about it is the
world war ii versus the holocaust
we were talking just now about the way
that history unrolls itself and
could hitler have been stopped and i i
don't quite
know what to think about hitler without
the holocaust
and perhaps in his thinking
how essential the anti-semitism and the
hatred of
jews was
it feels to me that
i mean i don't know we were just talking
about where did he pick up his hatred
of the jewish people there's uh there's
stories in vienna and so on
that it almost is picking up the
idea of anti-semitism as a really useful
tool
as opposed to actually believing in its
core
do you think world war ii as it turned
out and hitler's
as he turned out would be possible
without
anti-semitism could we have avoided the
holocaust
or was it an integral part of
the ideology of fascism and the nazis
not an integral part of fascism because
mussolini really i mean
mussolini did it to please hitler but it
wasn't an integral part
what's interesting to me is that that's
the big anomaly in the whole question
because
anti-semitism didn't need to be a part
of this at all
right hitler had a conspiratorial view
of the world
he was a believer that the jews
controlled things right the jews were
responsible
for both bolshevism on one side and
capitalism on the other they ruled the
banks i mean the united states was a
jewifide country right
uh bolshevism was was a a jewifide
sort of a a political in other words he
saw jews
everywhere and he had that line about if
the jews of europe
force another war to germany they'll pay
the price or whatever but then you have
to believe that they're capable of that
that the holocaust is a weird weird
sidebar to the whole thing and here's
what i've always found interesting
it's a sidebar that weakened germany
because look at the first world war
jews fought for germany right who was
the most
important and this is a very arguable
point but it's just the first one that
pops into my head
who was the most important jewish figure
that would have maybe been on the german
side had the germans had a
non-anti-semitic
well listen that whole part yeah yeah
science type but the whole
i should point out that to say germany
or europe or russia or any of those
things were not
anti-semitic is to do injustice to
history right right pogroms everywhere i
mean
yes that is that it's standard operating
procedure
what what you see in the hitlerian era
is an absolute huge
spike right because the government has a
conspiracy theory
that the jews have it's funny because
hitler both thought of them as weak and
super powerful at the same time right
and
and as an outsider people that we can
join the whole idea of the blood and how
that connects to darwinism and and
all that sort of stuff is just weird
right a real outlier
but einstein let's just play with
einstein
if there's no anti-semitism in germany
or or none above the normal level right
um the baseline level um does einstein
leave
along with all the other uh jewish
scientists and
i mean and what does germany have as as
increased technological
and intellectual capacity if they stay
right it's something that actually
weakened that state it's it's a tragic
flaw
in in the hitlerian worldview but it was
so
and and i don't let me you had mentioned
earlier like maybe it was
not integral to his character maybe it
was a wonderful
tool for power i don't think so
somewhere along the line and really
not at the beginning this guy became
absolutely obsessed
with this with a conspiracy theory and
jews and and and he surrounded himself
uh with people and theorists i'm going
to use that word
really really sort of loosely who
believed this too and so you have a
cabal of people who are reinforcing this
idea
that the jews control the world that
inter he called it international jewry
was a huge part of the problem and that
because of that they deserve to be
punished they were an enemy within
all these kinds of things it's a it's a
nutty conspiracy theory
that the government of one of the most i
mean the big thing with germany was
culture right they were
they were they were a leading figure in
in culture and philosophy and all these
kinds of things and that they
could be overtaken with this
wildly wickedly weird conspiracy theory
and that it would actually determine
things
i mean hitler was taking vast amounts of
german resources
and using it to wipe out this race when
he needed them for all kinds of other
things to fight a war of annihilation so
that is the weirdest part of of the
whole nazi
phenomenon it's the the darkest possible
silver lining to think about is that the
holocaust
may have been in the hatred of the
jewish people may have been the thing
that avoided
germany getting the nuclear weapons
first
and and
isn't that a wonderful historical ironic
twist that if it weren't so
overlaid with tragedy a thousand years
from now will be seen as something
really kind of funny well that's
that's true it's fascinating to think as
you've talked
so the seeds of his own destruction
right the tragic flaw
you